all right let's talk about old joe biden
because that whole insurrection thing
that i just talked about that
insurrection thing uh was about the
election of joe biden and uh 81 million
people that's what they told us voted
for joe biden that's an awful lot of
people it's actually the most people
that ever voted for a president in the
history of the united states and if you
don't remember the second most people
that ever voted for president united
states were donald trump in the exact
same election he got about 75 million
votes according to what they tell us and
i don't want to be kicked off youtube
for even saying that some of that may be
a little fudged i don't know
but
biden's approval numbers are absolutely
in the tank right now we've got a tweet
here from tom bevin biden job approval
in a new quinnipiac poll is 33
among adults and just 25
with independence among registered
voters it's 35
i mean this is
extraordinarily low like this is like
just like bananas low and if you think
about it think how soft the media has
been on him right there's really no
criticism of joe biden in mainstream
media really just try to think for a
second has nbc abc cbs cnn all the usual
suspects have they done anything really
critical of him guy you know he was
going to shut down the virus then two
weeks ago oh no there's nothing i could
do kick it back to the states which by
the way is what the orange guy wanted
the entire time like he has failed at
every
possible level we're at about 10 i think
it's 9.7 percent inflation right now and
it's like that that is an incredibly
high number people don't realize that
means in essence you have 10 percent
less money right if you have 500 bucks
and inflation goes up by 10 you're
losing 50 bucks now you got 450 bucks in
essence the number in your bank account
may be the same but it doesn't have the
same value like we know that the thing
ain't working that's what it sounds like
joe biden you know man the thing ain't
working okay well
it ain't working and even here in
florida where things are pretty damn
good you can see some of the residual
stuff related to uh supply chain we went
into two targets to buy some stuff for
our new house we needed some plates just
temporarily while our stuff comes from
la we need some plates couple other
things and there were a lot of barren
shelves there really were not like
massively massively empty here florida's
obviously doing a better job moving some
stuff and they're getting people to work
but it wasn't it wasn't perfect here but
33 is extraordinarily low especially for
a guy that you know got these 81 million
votes people are actually waking up
despite the media protecting the guy and
of course you would just have to
contrast that with how the media treated
orange man who i'm pretty sure michael
maybe you could check on this what was
donald trump's lowest ever approval
rating i think it floated around 40
percent despite endless attacks on him
right so the media was always going
after trump and i think he floated
around 40 now you've got biden around 33
despite like some pretty great coverage
so i'll see if we can get that number in
just a sec but i thought you know what
we played this clip yesterday
where we contrasted some of
ron desantis state of the state speech
with some of joe biden's best hits and
as we were putting together the
compilation of joe biden we watched the
full corn pop video you all remember the
corn pop video joe biden at the pool
talking about the thing
well we watched it and i was like you
know we have to show this full video to
people it's so insane it's just so
absolutely insane and this moment this
two or so minute video that we're about
to show you this should have derailed
his entire thing people should have
watched this video and said this man is
clinically insane and should not be
president let's go i learned a lot and i
learned that uh
it makes a difference this was the
driving board area
and i was one of the guards
and they weren't allowed it was a three
meter board and you fell off sideways
you landed on the damn the darn cement
over there
and corn pop was a bad dude
and he ran a bunch of bad boys
and i did yeah he and back in those days
the shot things have changed
one of the things you had to use if you
used pomade in your hair you had to wear
a bathing cap
and so he was up on the board one
listening i said hey esther you off the
board i'll come up and drag you off
well he came off
and he said i'll meet you outside my car
this was mostly these were all public
housing behind it
my car there was a gate out here i
parked my car outside the gate
and i he said i'll be waiting for you
who's waiting for three guys in straight
razors not a joke
there's a guy named bill wright mouse
the only white guy and he did all the
pools he was the mechanic
and i said what am i going to do he said
come down here in the basement where the
mechanics were where all the pool filter
is you know the chain used to be a chain
that went across the deep end and he cut
off a six foot length of chain he fold
up he said you walk out with that chain
and you walk to the car and say you may
cut me man but i'm going to wrap this
chain around your head
i said you're kidding me
he said no if you don't don't come back
and he was right
so i walked out with the chain
and i walked up to my car
and they had those days you used to
remember the straight razors bang them
on the curb get them rusty put them in a
rain barrel get them rusty
and i looked at them but i was smart
then i said first of all i said when i
tell you get off the board you get off
the board i'll kick you out again but i
shouldn't have called you esther
williams i apologize for that
i apologize but i know that apology is
going to work he said you apologize to
me i said i apologize for that not for
throwing you out but i apologize for
what i said
he said okay close the straight razor my
heart began to beat again
i hope you enjoyed that because as many
times as i've seen it it makes less
sense each time and as a matter of fact
i thought let's play a little game with
this thing
if any of you
within three sentences can explain
what joe biden was saying right there
i will give you 500
that's what i'm going to commit to doing
if you can explain that in a sane
functional non-jokey non-sarcastic way
if you can tell me what joe biden was
saying there with the roaches and the
leg hair and corn pop and the cement etc
etc i will give you 500 american dollars
you can submit
your
explanations at reubenreport.locals.com